Antony on poursuit la chronique sport on
s'intéresse au football à présent oui
football féminin la S Montini de de de
de féminin a reçu de Montini j'allais
dire Montini oui a été à l'honneur cette
semaine puisque le club a reçu le label
d'école de football féminin seul le PSG
le parissaggermain possède ce label dans
le département alors Valérie Olibo oribo
et hoimoine ont voulu comprendre les
raisons de ce succès
valè 2e division une autre en Division
d'Honneur et la dernière en promotion de
ligue trois équipes trois niveaux
seniors qui permettent au plus jeunes
d'imaginer l'avenir mercredi dernier la
Fédération Française de Football décerné
pour la 2e année consécutive un label
d'excellence à l'école de foot féminin
de Montini le Bretonneux le label
représente la récompense justement d'un
d'un club structuré parce qu'on a un bon
accueil on fait une bonne formation avec
des éducatrices
diplômées et on on forme des jeunes on a
le nombre suffisant voilà on a tout ce
qu'il faut le label récompense
l'encadrement les installations et
équipements et soulligne le gage de
sérieux d'une école un sérieux qui a
porté ses fruits puisque certaines
joueuses ont déjà participé à des stages
ou des compétitions en équipe de France
au club certaines parmi les plus jeunes
voient déjà l'avenir en grand
professionnel à Lyon ou peut-être à
l'étranger en
Amérique dans les evelines Montini le
Bretonneux fait figure d'exception c'est
la Seu équipe a possédé ce label avec
celle du pariss-germain qui sera
labellisé à son tour pour la seconde
fois jeudi
prochain ce weekend chez les chez les
seniors lais Montini s'est incliné sur
la pelouse de Graveline plutôt séchement
d'ailleurs sur le score de de 4 buts à 1
les in Montaine reste dans le ventre mou
de leur poule de Division 2 on continue
avec les résultats du judo à présent oui
judo il y avait le tournoi international
de judo de trappe ce weekend qui a fêté
dignement ses 20 ans plus de 1500
combattants toute catégorie confondu se
sont à affronté au gymnase Paul maillet
un tournoi qui doit son succès grâce à
son label ceinture noire des délégations
étrangères étaient aussi présentes
combattants algériens et Belg et
hollandais une bonne note particulière à
la délégation algérienne qui a trusté
les podiums avec trois médailles le
samedi chez les combattants trapistes il
faut aller du côté des moins de 87 kg
avec un 8e de finaliste mais le tournoi
international de judo de trappe c'était
aussi l'opportunité pour les baby judo
de trappe de voir évoluer les plus
grands à côté du
tatami on écoute cette interview
interview du professeur de
trappe Patrick si l'interview est prête
le B Jud ça commence à partir de 4 ans
jusqu'à 5 ans et après 6 ans il ils sont
poussins les petits poussins
et ce ne sont pas des du judo Fondamenta
mais ce sont que de l'apprentissage que
des jeux à base de
jeu on continue avec les résultats sur
cette page de sport Anthony du basket et
du hand le basket les féinines de le LCV
l'entente le chînet Versailles ne se
lassent pas de la victoire tout
simplement cette fois-ci les espoirs
d'aras étaient leur victime ce weekend
score finale 66 à 47 pour le LCV une 8e
victoire consécutive en 8 journées
toujours invaincu et toujours solidement
leader de National 2 et donc du hand
hand B 7e journée de National 2 3e
victoire consécutive pour les
inimontaines qui relèvent bien la tête
le club de Montini a emporté 33 à 25
face à Gan et remonte à la 6e place de
leur championnat on va voir quelques
images de is de table à présent
compétition également qui se déroulait
ce weekend du côté de C nveline en probé
les fidèles encours se sont imposés à
domicile face à échirolébins sur le
score de 4 à0 sans discussion malgré
quelques premiers set accrochés les
joueuses de franc solniier confortent
leur 5e place au classement de probé
beaucoup de sport et à éoncour toujours
du roller quet les chocs d'éloncour les
chocs d'éloncours après le passage Coupe
de France ont retrouvé les joies du du
championnat de National 3 avec une
victoire plutôt facile face aux Ulis 5
buts à 2 l'objectif play-off est
toujours en ligne de miè et puis il
fallait aimer la pluie pour participer à
la rando castor cette année n'est-ce pas
Anthony oui oui la pluie la rando la
randonnée au castor dont les ordinateur
était venu sur le plateau lundi une
course d'orientation qui avait lieu ce
weekend cette année les circuits étaient
très techniques et comme vous l'aviez
dit vous l'avez dit très humide le
dimanche 796 participants étaient au
départ le vainqueur a bouclé le parcours
de 22 km en 2h 6 minutes il s'agit de
juste rimbo sur la version famille la
mini au castor les parents n'étaient pas
de trop pour résoudre les énigmes du
parour avec les enfants merci an donc
pour cette page sport d'être venu sur ce
plateau ce soir on vous retrouve lundi
prochain au mêm Hir et on passe
maintenant à la santé pour conclure ce